The next question on the WhatsApp. My
name is Rafanulhak. I am a student from
Bangladesh. My question is many atheists
claim that can Allah create a stone that
he cannot lift. I generally answer them
by saying that this question is
illogical and self-contradictory. But
they say that Allah is transcendent
and he's not bound by any
contradictions. Since he is not bound by
any contradictions, so why he can't
create a stone that he cannot lift? So
how to answer this question? And this is
a common question asked even in the
times of when I was in school that can
go create anything and everything and we
say yes. Can God destroy anything and
everything? And we say yes. So can God
create a stone which he cannot destroy?
And you're stuck. If you say yes also
you're wrong. If you say no also you're
wrong. And similar question can God
create anything and everything? We say
yes. Can God lift anything and
everything? We said yes. So can he
create a stone which he cannot lift? So
these questions actually as you rightly
said they are illogical because for
example if I say that there is a tall
short man it doesn't have any meaning.
You can either have a tall man or a
short man or you can have a medium man.
You can't have a tall short man. It's
meaningless. For example, if I say that
there's a fat thin man. You either have
a fat man or a thin man. You can't have
a fat thin man because it's meaningless.
So similarly, Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
only does godly things. He does not do
ungodly things like creating a stone
which he cannot lift. Like Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala he does not lie
because to lie is against the concept of
Allah subhanaa tala. Allah Allah says in
the Quran he's never unjust. Allah
subhananaa tala cannot do injustice.
Allah says in surah nah 4 verse number
40 he is never unjust in the least
degree. Furthermore Allah says that
Allah subhanana wa tala never forgets.
Allah says in surah chapter number 20
verse number 52 Allah never forgets. So
Allah cannot forget. It is against the
the benevalence of Allah subhananaa tala
to forget. So here we say that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is all powerful and
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala cannot do
ungodly things. Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala only does godly things. He
doesn't do ungodly things. That's the
reason Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is the
highest and is we learn from the s of
the prophet and the incidences which
increases our iman. Hope that answers
this question.